problema número 61 si un kilómetro es
aproximadamente punto 6 millas cuál de
los siguientes se aproxima mejor a la
cantidad de kilómetros en dos millas nos
dicen entonces qué
un kilómetro
es aproximadamente igual a puntos 6
millas
as
proximadamente igual y nos preguntan
cuántos kilómetros habrá en dos millas
podemos establecer una proporción
podemos decir que hay puntos seis millas
dos millas entre dos millas
esto es igual a un kilómetro entre no sé
incógnita vamos a llamarla x
podemos hacer una multiplicación cruzada
dejar 0.6 millas
por equis iguala
un kilómetro por dos millas
esto es x en km
y nos quedaría punto 6x igualados porque
1 por 2 esos entonces nos queda que x es
igual a 2
/ 0.6
esto es igual a 20 en 36 y esto lo
podemos simplificar un poco más
dejándolo como 10 entre 3 lo cual tiene
sentido ya que una milla es más larga
que un kilómetro así que dos millas son
diez tercios de kilómetro que es nuestra
opción
el siguiente problema
número 62 mariana invirtió 10 mil
dólares en un nuevo fondo de inversión
hace tres años el valor de la cuenta se
incrementó 10 por ciento del primer año
se incrementó 5 por ciento el segundo
año y se decremento 10 por ciento el
tercer año cuál es el valor de la cuenta
hoy ok entonces nos dicen que se
invirtió 10 mil dólares en el primer año
se incrementó un 10 por ciento
en el segundo año se incrementó un 5% y
para el tercer año se decremento un 10%
ok entonces esto lo podemos expresar
como
nuestra inversión inicial o la de
marianna 10.000 por 1.1 que representa
el aumento en 10% 1.1
por el aumento del 5% lo describimos
como un 1.05
decremento que lo escribimos como 0.9 y
hacemos esta operación ok entonces de
10.000 por 1.1 esto de acá es igual a
11011 mil
11.000 x 1.05
esto por un 1.05 es igual
vamos a hacerlo aquí en un lado 11.000
por un 1.05
0 0 0550 va aquí todos estos son ceros
el 1 puesto 11.000 por unos 11.000
con 1000 de manera que el resultado es 0
005 511 y con los dos lugares decimales
recorremos 1 2
aquí nos va a quedar entonces que esta
multiplicación es de 11.550 esto es 11
ahora esto lo voy a multiplicar por
punto 9 por el decremento en 10 por
ciento está por 0.9 así que
11.550 por 0.9
esto es por esto es por esto fue más
9 x 0 0 9 por 5 45 9 por 5 45 449
llevamos 4 9 x 19 + 4 13 9 por el 9 9
por 19 + 11
y tenemos un lugar decimal esto lo
recorremos acá de manera que nos va a
quedar 10.395 esta multiplicación
es de 10 mil 395
dólares esta es nuestra respuesta veamos
el siguiente problema número 63 un
productor de circuitos de computadora
espera que la proporción de circuitos
defectuosos con respecto al total de
circuitos en todos los futuros envíos
sea igual a la correspondiente por
porción de los envíos de 1 a 4
combinados como se muestra en esta tabla
cuál será el número de circuitos
defectuosos en un envío de 60 mil
circuitos ésta es la tabla aquí está el
identificador del envío el número de
circuitos defectuosos en cada envío y el
total de circuitos enviados por cada
envío primero tenemos que encontrar el
porcentaje de los efectos en todos los
envíos de la tabla
como es la combinación de todos estos
envíos vamos a ver el total de
defectuoso 6 2 5 7 6 13 + 4 17
y aquí el total de circuitos enviados
son 12 30 25 12 17 + 18 25 más
16 51
esto es 51 así que el total son 51 mil y
nos piden cuál es la diferencia de los
defectuosos o la proporción de los
efectos con respecto al total aquí 17 de
cada 51 miles son defectuosos pero
quizás se hayan dado cuenta de que 51
mil es divisible entre 17 de hecho es
divisible tres veces así que podemos
decir que hay un circuito defectuoso por
cada 3.000 circuitos enviados si
combinamos los envíos del 1 al 4
si tenemos esta misma proporción en 60
mil
circuitos enviados cuántos grupos de
3000 hay en 60 mil pues va a haber
nuestra incógnita es igual
a 60 mil
entre 3000
pues habrá 20 grupos de 3000 en 60.000 y
ustedes pueden calcular a ojo esto pero
hay varias maneras de calcular pero el
resultado es que se esperan 20 circuitos
defectuosos en 60 mil circuitos totales
que es nuestra opción b
ahora pasemos al último problema de este
vídeo
número 64 dos enteros se seleccionarán
de manera aleatoria de los conjuntos que
se muestran a continuación un entero del
conjunto a otro entero del conjunto ver
cuál es la probabilidad de que la suma
de los dos enteros sea igual a 9 qué
combinaciones de números en ambos
conjuntos me dan 9 bueno si yo elijo 2
de a tengo que elegir 7 debe para que de
9 si yo elijo 3 de a voy a tener que
elegir 6 de b si yo elijo 4 de edad voy
a tener que elegir 5 debe para que de 9
la suma y si elijo 5 de agua ya tener
que seleccionar 4 debe voy a elegir un
número en a y dependiendo del número que
salga debe de elegir el número correcto
en vail al elegir un número de edad
tendremos que tener el número correcto
debe y debe pues vamos a tener una
probabilidad de 1 entre 5 ya que son 5
elementos en el conjunto b debe tener el
número que necesitamos para que la suma
se 9
un quinto es lo mismo que 0.2 qué
nuestra opción b espero que esto lo
hayan entendido ya que no nos importa
que el número seleccionamos cenar pero
para poder tener 9 como suma tengo que
elegir específicamente uno de los cinco
números de b con una probabilidad de un
quinto que tengamos el número que
queremos si elijo el 2 en la tengo que
elegir 7 en b si elijo 3 en nada debo
tener 6 en b si elijo o sale 4 en y
tengo que tener en b por fuerza 5 y si
sale 50 voy a tener que elegir 4 en b y
todas estas probabilidades son de un
quinto probabilidad de un quinto para
esta opción un quinto para esta 1 en 3 5
para esta otra y también 1 entre 5 para
esta por lo que una vez elegido el
número de a hay un quinto de
probabilidad de que el número que
necesito para que la suma sean 9 sale
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo